you are constantly I mean just now
you're talking you're analyzing Society
but also yourself but also what does
money mean there's so much that you're
thinking about all the time and it all
goes back to this I want you to say
compulsion yes to
think and consider everything yes and
you talk a lot about OCD and how you've
been battling OCD really your entire
life yeah I mean now it's not so bad
because you know once you find out what
the thing is you know you go to it and
then they go oh that's just that and you
go oh once you put a name on it yeah
once you put it you take away its power
yeah yeah so
um yeah I have intrusive uh ocds which
usually are taboo thoughts so whatever
is Taboo in your Society you know when
you were a kid yeah you told your mother
yes because it's in the book you told
your mother that you had these thoughts
of harming the family yes and she said
honey it's okay if you're gay
all right well
now you just say oh
yep that's how that's how a gay person
comes out I'm thinking of murdering the
family and somehow being homosexual was
worse in the 80s than being a serial
killer right right why can't you be more
like Ted Bundy he's heterosexual
now at least like the ladies you say you
say that your mom because you talk a lot
about your mom and you talk about how
she was kind of you think one of the
catalysts or one of the
maybe moving forces behind you getting
into Show Business totally why my mom
well she loves things that are shiny but
she also and this is something I
realized after she passed I always
thought she had like style like she knew
what was the best thing and now I
realize oh she just choiced chose to see
everything she got as the best so this
microphone is just darling no you can
tell it's quality it's made it's
handcrafted by someone in the water oh I
love it Conan I love it
I'm a lucky kitty
but that's that's actually a lovely
quality yes and so how does that
translate into you wanting to go into
Show Business well because she was often
distracted which I think may have been a
result of not getting enough calories
but uh you know always sort of like it
needed it needed to have some shine on
it so my sister became a physician that
seemed to get her enough attention like
oh well my my older daughter is a is a
doctor and she has four children with
her husband
Mark and then you know and then it was
sort of me on my end it was quiet for a
number of years well Maria's just
figuring it out she's just figuring it
out but like oh my God as soon as you
know she has been well the first TV spot
I got was on your show you know that's
in 1999 I think yeah you came on Late
Night Conan she's on television like she
would just light up about uh yeah
consumer or anything with a
yes she loves status and I've talked
about this I think before in the podcast
but I have this picture on my desk that
someone took when I was at an event it
was my parents it's probably 15 years
ago and it's both of my parents laughing
really hard because I'm on stage in the
picture I'm not in the picture it's just
both my parents laughing really hard and
I asked someone showed me that picture
and I said could I have that and I
framed it and I keep on my desk because
if anyone ever needs the reason why and
it's very Primal yeah but it is see
those two people that made me laughing
that's why that's why that's the whole
thing and as you know I'm wondering if
it's I'm guess I've in your book you
make it clear that when you get up on
stage and you get that kind of approval
and laughter it does resonate because
you've felt it before it's when you were
a kid and your parents were going yay
videos for Papa yeah
oh it's just delightful I don't know if
anybody's heard of uh Suzuki violin or
that's a it's it's a way people teach
their kids music and it came out of
Japan and it all is all about if you
teach a kid early enough they can do
anything so you start at two years old
you will have a weirdly you know uh
talented
whatever it is very unhappy yes perhaps
unhappy dependent times
but you can you know kids can do
anything so so and you talk about this
in the book because you did Suzuki
violin what age did you start three now
whose idea was it your mommy or dad well
they said honey you can do dance or
violin and I didn't really know what
either of those were yeah you're three I
was three so I said why not the V sound
and then uh started doing that no what
little did I know what she said which I
didn't understand that either she said
you cannot quit and two you're 12 years
old and I didn't understand time and how
how that worked but
um yeah I mean the great thing about
that it kept me off the pipe off the
pole and also uh actually it's something
you could use on the pole yeah yeah and
also something you should start at two
or three yeah yeah to get really good
yeah I mean you want to work out those
muscles on the pole but yeah I mean can
kids are incredibly malleable and if
they if you look as a parent that you're
pleased at the actions that they're you
know performing whether that's factory
work in a chicken parts uh situation or
they you will do it you will continue to
do it and get better how good did you
get at piano using this method I got I
mean piano violent yeah I mean be funny
if you got really good at the piano
that'd be very strange uh you know
weirdly good where you go ah wow that's
crazy you know where uh I think I got to
book eight out of ten and I went to the
interlocking Music Camp International uh
music camp did it give you any Joy
not really I did not enjoy it the part I
liked was getting up on stage I like
that part and then um I kind of like the
feel of Victory like if I whooped
somebody like if somebody didn't do well
and then I did well like which is
monstrous and yeah but I I what I liked
more was uh getting laughs and stuff
because I did some theater and stuff as
a kid and speeches yeah Ira when I uh
in our you know I went to Catholic you
know the whole Catholic rigamarole uh
which is how the that's how the Vatican
likes you to refer to it now and uh
St Lawrence Church Brookline
Massachusetts and and early on they just
noticed that I you know oh this kid
speak enunciates and he seems to clean
up okay you be the one that reads the
little passages you know from the New
Testament nice so I was a kid and I had
that experience of I'd get up in front
of the congregation and I would read you
know and Luke said to the Corinthians
you know what sayeth you on that day
Jesus and I would read those
and I remembered
this material is no good like yeah this
material is like there's not it really I
mean no I'm sorry it's not funny no it's
it's and this material doesn't have it
doesn't have the goods and I could sense
sometimes like oh this is a good crowd
because I'd hear the priest before me
you know father Dwyer would get some
laughs and I'd be up there with my
Corinthians and I saith to you and then
the Palms were were you know were cut
down on the sheaves and I'm thinking no
this isn't the right material but okay
church was my first time seeing stand up
I got to see a white guy have a hot take
on a weird story uh you know like it's
it's church is very much like a public
speaking it's the first thing yeah and
so that was where I got like a little
taste yeah of what it could be could be
good yeah and uh so I understand that
idea of okay you're on stage with a
violin and you're quickly realizing I
don't I don't really want the violin up
here with me well and I did that at
first because I thought well at least I
can kind of make people happy with this
guy didn't really want to bomb but I uh
or yeah people will be acceptable or
except that I'm good at something and
then then I can hit him with my ideas
and uh nobody wanted that and uh but
then I moved to Los Angeles there were
two other comedians who were female uh
doing uh acts with violence and so I
said to myself I think I I can kick this
to the curb now